[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you did a thing last night that was very
european you kissed my hand three times
yeah absolutely is that a [ __ ] new
york thing no
he thought you were king john
yeah i said he got confused yeah
i was paying respect to the dear leader
oh you were that's what it was yeah yeah
respect yeah maybe it's a white people
thing
no you know what i think it is bobby i'm
just like no just don't put your fingers
that don't first of all first of all you
know what you're getting no your gaze
your days of pointing fingers at little
asian people is over oh no no no they're
just beginning
no no no you guys know i'm a trump
supporter right so don't worry
i mean
you're going to get away you're going to
get away with it you got the right look
but if you're speaking our language
right now yeah i think he's just making
good choice after a good choice and a
[ __ ] cut down hollywood wants to say
something different they can say it
we're in bobby's [ __ ] mansion right
now and it's what it is
yeah
i was kidding
oh yeah no me too
any show i got on in the beginning would
be doing the open mics and then either
you know bringing three people handing
out flyers or but most of them were
uh hey i have a bar show i don't know
who you are but heard you're a physical
therapist which is a doctor to them can
you take a look at my back or my knee or
so many dicks i'm not even trying to be
funny it's like so many comedians would
be like can you look at my penis for
what for like something wrong stds and
i'd be like but i'm a physical therapist
like i can i give massages
they were like yeah look at my dick look
at my dick and i'd be like look i'm not
licensed to tell you this
but it is her piece
i get why the japanese had to do what
they had to do we were not treating them
fairly treating them like second class
citizens since world war one and then
they came and then we stopped [ __ ]
paying for their oil we stopped the oil
we said we're not giving you any more
oil to take over [ __ ] china so they
said listen babe the only way
we're gonna
have to try to blow your blow the
pacific feet out of the ocean it didn't
work and then the whole country got put
in a microwave but that's just what's
gonna happen you know and but i'm not
but what i'm saying is you mess with the
boys
you mess with the boys you woke up the
boys yeah it's a situation it's
unfortunate that that happened but i do
not blame the japanese for doing what
they did and i also you know war is
disgusting it's ugly and it sucks but
it's not going anywhere but you know but
do you think just this is probably open
for debate but do you think that
nuclear bombs was a little too much i
think the second it's a little
heavy-handed yeah right i think i guess
i think i'll say this i think the second
one was a lot this you didn't have to do
the second one
and the first one is debatable i don't i
wouldn't have chose to use it but but
the other think about the other options
from the from the allies point of view
they said we're going to lose a million
soldiers if we invade tokyo so or we can
just drop some nuclear juice on these
people and see what happens yeah and i
don't i don't think it was right i don't
think it was right what the united
states did i do not don't call it juice
truman kept saying he kept saying in
japan he said just give up your
country's laws give up and the japanese
pride said we're not going to do what
we're not going to do we're not going to
do it so he said you're giving us no
choice either you give up by today and
we're not and and or you're going to be
a bento box and then that's what
happened you know what i mean and and i
and i know that that's unfortunate what
the [ __ ] up yeah shut the [ __ ] up yeah
i'm just and i'm everyone's gonna be a
little traumatized after yeah
all right i'm an instigator yes i don't
care
i am one why are you why are you deaf
all of a sudden what are you talking
about
are you a mute i don't know i look like
john stamos is like [ __ ] brother
special needs that's what they call me
my special needs that's my idea that's
okay and we also call him and we also
call him jani almost because he's you
know he's
his his head is almost big enough he's
almost handsome he's almost got a big
enough dick he's almost had a career
he's come close and yeah and he's almost
gay that's the thing with us
is i'll say this about us is we're a
podcast number one we're a podcast it's
on the run we're just feeling like we
say [ __ ] yeah we're here for a good time
not a long time yeah the history hyenas
um
we can confidently confidently 100 tell
you we are not gay but we can also tell
you we are not straight yeah so so i
just don't you have some cake for your
birthday yeah a little bit i was playing
video games i have the headphones on
yeah and my brother and i were um
you know we're in a house
and we could hear footsteps coming in
right
and we're scared right i'm like steve
wait
flank him flank him right and i'm
upstairs with the gun right we already
had a loadout right so i have my loadout
right i'm you know my point right
all of us in here is
happy
birthday right literally right my
[ __ ] net clinched
like that and then my left arm came numb
and like i almost had a [ __ ] stroke i
turn around it's these [ __ ] little
[ __ ] island gooks
sneaky little island groups like they
did in [ __ ] platoon yeah right in
platoon
right remember right
they dig
they live in a tree for three weeks with
a banana and a [ __ ] handgun bananas
that's why they won the [ __ ] war
bananas good to lower blood pressure
yeah i know but yeah right but that's
how they want these little [ __ ]
little [ __ ] right yeah they know
where all the holes are yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] just hide in a hole for
[ __ ] a month
they snatch them she put it on instagram
did you guys put that up on instagram
the video right i almost had a [ __ ]
stroke so you know when when i get you
know oh well your dad did die of a
stroke yeah dude all my family members
right have had strokes and they've been
paralyzed from the neck down they smoke
cigarettes though cigarette syndrome too
oh you smoke two okay yeah okay so you
know i told you about my grandmother for
25 years she never left the house right
and you know i told you about the welts
and stuff didn't you have a grandmother
too who got run over by tank or
something
what was that story oh [ __ ] you told me
that on tiger on tiger belly yeah i had
an aunt
you know mean who was run over by a
military oh there it is
dressed like freddy
krueger it's so funny i like at the end
the last part when they just still look
at his face
[Laughter]
i would have came at the end and hit him
with a [ __ ] wiffle ball bat it's
interesting you say that because i did
the ancestry.com and i thought my whole
life i was half italian half irish like
every other white piece of [ __ ] from any
big city but it found that i'm almost 80
german
um so it is interesting to say the
schiller thing because i have a little
bit of the nazi thing you know
no no i i like i like everybody i
understand that i don't want to push
anybody i mean you know i am for the
wall and i you know but but
i want i want to make sure everyone has
their passport because you guys are
looking at me and it's i'm getting a
little you know i'm getting a feeling
the walls are coming but i want to say
this but i don't want to hurt any jews
right i know you don't but you didn't
even have to go
right ancestry you could have just
called me and i would have said you're
80 percent journalist you look at that
face yeah you see schindler's list yeah
they all look like you bro i remember
like one time pif the magic dragon came
in and he was a little late and i felt
bad because like i am stuck in traffic
he's got his [ __ ] dragon costume on
even though he sells tickets
jesus it's gonna suck him no yeah
american got he got america's got talent
yeah like one american's got to tell
he's got millions of dollars but he's
got to walk around in a [ __ ] dragon
suit yeah and i remember he was like
magic yeah so you know you feel bad
you're like what the [ __ ] this kid's in
the dragon suit it was the summer time
but he's got to do it it's the act he's
making real money so so he sat down and
i was they had some sandwich shop that
come with sandwiches and i went to go
give pif a piece of sandwich because i
felt bad and jim norman was like don't
give him any food this isn't a [ __ ]
fort and then he just
and then jim and then
he said and i was like i was trying to
give the kid a sandwich she goes you
give him a piece of food get the [ __ ]
off my show and i was like oh this is
great you know he said this isn't a fort
yeah yeah
yeah is everyone really molested here or
yeah yeah yeah yeah for real
not this one i don't know you guys no he
wasn't now just yeah all right you're
unmolestable that's all i was a really
cute we played a basketball team instead
of shirts and skins it would be molested
you have a really good three-on-three
game
yeah well i also know a female comedian
that we all know that's a popular
podcast i want to say her name but she
had you know a somebody
show up at her house i believe it that
was like repping another podcast right
and going i know where you live you know
so it's yeah you know and you know that
happens and that's [ __ ] scary [ __ ]
sure of course of course someone just
sent me bananas to my front door because
we have a banana break on our podcast
that's good you know how creepy that is
bananas
random bananas yeah potassium they're
good for potassium
they are a little high in fat low high
in calories yeah i've been doing my
fitness pal and they're about 150 cows
large bananas you know something that
you mentioned earlier too it's like you
know other comedians canceling others i
don't trust guys with no shoelaces by
the way i don't trust george at all
anymore about
velcro i can deal with because you know
it's like you're [ __ ]
is that because god didn't concentrate
when they were making us i don't know i
don't know i i it's my father something
though right i know where you're going i
know where you're fishing tonight
because i feel like he right when he
made you yeah he took a day yeah like
he's like
get the chins in right get that
right and all that stuff right and he
concentrated right but with me he went
like this
does this guy need a chin no but we need
a billion of us too yeah a lot of you
guys were making them just pop up and
just throw them down
white dudes like you yeah you really
well i think it's i think god's german
that's why
and i think the wrong people won the war
i'm just not kidding
i just remember like like i could i
don't go to bed to like i've always been
like that four or five in the morning
yeah so
mind you and i'm starving
you can't go to the kitchen before you
know what i mean after ten yeah so then
i'm like starving three in the morning
no money
right
in a dark attic with a quilt
it's freezing right
trembling right and like you start
thinking things like should i just get
out of the business
why don't you go downstairs and just get
food they wouldn't let you they had like
a rule that you couldn't and you didn't
want a creek i don't want a creek also i
don't i don't know i don't know don't
you have those little white people but
these little shoes those little tiny
shoes that tie your feet don't you bind
your feet don't you guys bind your feet
at night
to make your toes smaller yeah how did
you eat did you bring your own
chopsticks or did you just use their
utensils how do you eat so much pizza
with chopsticks
[Laughter]
you didn't want to go downstairs you
want to get out of the business but then
what what woke you up to stay in the
business huh the money the checks
bobby close your eyes
close your eyes
count to three
we're just kidding that's so racist i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding
that's the most racist thing you've ever
heard well when i'm i'm i'm my eyes are
obviously closed
right and there's nothing oh there's
close your eyes
right
you really couldn't tell well okay close
them now let me see oh yeah no not
really can't really [ __ ] tell
the person
they didn't even know the people in
indiana didn't even know you were asian
probably they just thought you had
allergies or something
who do people say looks like what what
do you think um uh who do you look like
um bruno mars or uh bruno that's a good
one bruno mars thank you yeah yeah i
would say i would say yeah bruno mars i
would say tiki statue
[Laughter]
i'd rather not do the gig than do the
condo be and it's not a i think i'm so
good thing it's just a club owner right
yes and you're headlining right yes and
and i say to you you come and i go
hey chris big fan haha love the high i
know yeah podcast it's great oh yeah
yeah but um
uh we love it and that the punjab what's
this like a hairy guy that you'll do it
with oh wow
oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's turkish
very funny guy yeah easy punjab or yeah
yanni smallheads yeah so um anyway um
there's no green room because um you
know during the day we do this um you
know we do a one-man show you know todd
mcgiverns is doing a one-man show he's
[ __ ] so funny so funny
you know he's doing a one-man show about
his trauma and how he was he was
molested by pygmies oh really oh bobby
lee doesn't act just like that yeah yeah
yeah
and uh and then i walked the [ __ ]
italian guy um
yeah so and then he goes anyway so
there's no green room and um it's weird
it's like we're you do great numbers for
us thank you so much but we don't really
have any water for you so if you can go
across the street and go to the
just go get your some water if you want
some right no green room and you get
your own water we have a hallway next to
the bathroom so just we have a couch
there you can just hang out there yeah
what would you say
uh initially i would i would have just
done it and taken it but today yeah
today i would i would just say no you
have to you have to go you have to go
get me water i would tell him you have
to [ __ ] go get me water and then uh
and then if he didn't i obviously you
know because i'm a us passport whatever
i brandish my weapon
and i put it in his [ __ ] mouth
and
and i'd say listen [ __ ] nuts yeah yeah
either you go get me some [ __ ]
aquafinas right now and some jelly
donuts with some straws because i've
never done drugs so instead i snort the
jelly yeah yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] put
two in the back of your skull i'm gonna
get gonna uh get away with it because my
father's a criminal that's what i'd say
to you yeah yeah oh my god i have like a
list i have i revenge fantasies i have a
lot of revenge fantasies right and i
have a list of twelve hundred twelve
hundred twelve hundred probably names oh
my god of people that i would sell out
of the theater right
you guys sell at a theater with the
revenge you should do it the revenge
invite them all give them free tickets
yeah yeah yeah like that's like a
[ __ ] wilt chamberlain number of
people who offended you i know but you
know i'm trying to even do the math and
think how that's possible is that like
three people a day you said [ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
you